pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on leur cache au nouveau palais des
sports à paris tout est permis ou
presque dans cette spécialité
en tout cas un pas cela en prison toute
irrégularité trop grave en effet est
sanctionné d'une peine de prison sens là
où irions-nous vous allez voir
[Applaudissements]
on va se terminer ce petit duo
vous êtes bien présentes que mon ami et
voilà ça cpa
[Applaudissements]
mais vous n'avez encore rien vu avec
l'entrée les équipes féminines vous
allez enfin découvrir ce qu'est vraiment
le rôle hors cac c'est tout d'abord la
grâce
ça c'est de la provocation ce qui
entraîne les crises admiratif des
spectacles
et pour que le roller catch porte bien
son nom on ne répugne pas à se crêper le
chignon
allons messieurs allons voilà ce qu'il
en coûte de n'être pas galant
[Musique]
pour la dixième fois la loterie
nationale va jouer à longchamp c'est
donc un anniversaire populaire car si
apprécié cambran 51 et orfeo en 52
l'arrivée de dark knight en 53 déclenché
un enthousiasme c'est que toute la
france turfiste ou notre fils tu avais
joué le groupe
même chose en 1954 avec l'arrivée de
popov qui s'ils n'avaient rien inventé
en dépit de son nom avait fait pleuvoir
80 millions sur le numéro 09 179 et la
série continue à 55 56 ans 57 l'une des
plus belles arrivées avec altipan qu'ils
aient pour le gros lot 100 millions et
l'an dernier s'était birom qui
déclenchait la pluie d'or chaque année
la loterie nationale à fait trouvé la
fortune dans le pas d'un cheval
on attend les 150 millions du 10e
anniversaire avec le gagnant de 1960
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernière étape du tour d'italie
jacques anquetil n'a que 28 secondes
d'avancé sur l'italien nenshi ni son
rival le plus dangereux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sera suffisant cependant pour
permettre à l'ancien recordman du monde
de l'heure de conserver le maillot rouge
jusqu'à milan et d'être ainsi le premier
français à remporter le giro d'italie ce
tour d'honneur qu'il fait à milan quand
il n'aura pas l'occasion de le
renouveler cette année au parc des
princes puisque il renonce à courir le
tour de france
[Applaudissements]
embouteillage de péniches à l'entrée du
canal saint denis ce spectacle insolite
dû à la grève des éclusiers parisien a
préludé à d'autres événements dûe à la
grève des fonctionnaires pas de
douaniers dans les aéroports jour faste
pour la contrebande personne au guichet
de la poste pas de mandat pas de
courrier
[Musique]
pas d'école non plus portes closes une
déception pour les écoliers pendant ce
temps vingt mille fonctionnaires
parisiens sont allés manifester devant
le ministère des finances dont les
employés eux mêmes étaient en grève
journée et là sans lendemain or a
regretté le contribuable un peu raide
rennes en bretagne
l'homme du jour c'est monsieur de
l'alouette surnommé le pape de
l'artichaut à la tête du comité de
l'artichaut il dirige la révolte à saint
pol de léon
depuis quinze jours chaque matin au
marché de saint paul c'est la même chose
200 à 300 voitures arrivent bourg et
d'artichauts et le dialogue commence
entre les producteurs les expéditeurs
net catégorique 20 francs le kilo houria
les producteurs se sont organisés à la
mairie ils ont fait signer un arrêté
réglementant le marché est depuis quinze
jours la matinée se termine sur le même
spectacle 4 à 500 tonnes d'artichaut
invendus sont emmenés à la décharge
publique plutôt que d'être laissés à vil
prix mais aussi par cette hécatombe
vengeresse les exploitants bretons
espèrent attirer l'attention générale
sur un circuit de distribution qui les
livrent sans défense aux aléas d'un
système d'intermédiaires désuet et
condamnés qui n'avantage ni le
producteur ni le consommateur nous
sommes convaincus que le président
eisenhower ne courra en n'anticipent
aucun risque affirmé à tokyo monsieur
james nagati venu préparer le voyage
présidentiel mais il ajouté parce que le
gouvernement japonais fera le nécessaire
la réception fait trois heures plus tôt
au porte-parole de la maison blanche
avait été pourtant éloquente sa voiture
complètement bloquée par la foule des
manifestants il n'avait dû qu'à un
hélicoptère de la marine de ne pas
passer la totalité de son séjour à
l'entrée de l'aérodrome
ce sera la visite du président
eisenhower la gauche japonais semblent
décidés à lui a refusé le traditionnel
welcome
[Musique]
le lancement du jean paul getty qui
avait attiré à dunkerque de nombreuses
personnalités mérite l'attention à plus
d'un titre
doté d'une hélice de 36 tonnes la plus
lourde du monde
c'est le plus gros pétroliers jamais
construit en europe en outre son
lancement devait constituer un
chef-d'oeuvre de précisions ne disposant
que d'un bassin de 400 m les 257 m du
temps caire allait s'immobiliser à
quelques dizaines de mètres seulement du
quai d'en face
exc 97 milles tonnes de déplacement ce
géant transportera à chaque voyage une
cargaison qui pourrait faire rouler une
voiture de bishu beau jour et nuit
pendant dix iec
[Musique]
le référendum du film s'est achevée à
vichy par la distribution des prix
gabriel axel élèves de carl dreyer a
reçu une caméra d'or au nom du metteur
en scène danois pour le film dies irae
quant à la seconde destinée à
récompenser le meilleur sujet
d'actualité des dix dernières années est
remise à madame audibert présidente de
la presse filmée elle a été décerné aux
actualités françaises
[Musique]
à vingt ans de distance c'était 40 le
mois que nous vivons c'était dunkerque
dunkerque est ce qu'on s'en souvient
ceux qui étaient ceux qui en sont sortis
que penseront ils devant ces images
évadés vingt ans après de l'album de
famille
il n'ya pas que ceux de dunkerque il ya
les autres vous lui et moi c'est pour
nous aussi l'album de famille on avait
appris un mois avant que la drôle de
guerre n'était plus drôle du tout et que
la plus formidable armée du temps avec
des milliers de chars et des milliers
d'avions avait enfoncé le front réduit à
néant la défense belge et hollandaise
poussée des armées vers la mer et
qu'elle déferlé vers le coeur
j'avais entendu parler des grandes
rencontres de chat de résistance
victorieuse
[Musique]
des noms ont oubliées ou inconnues
éclater tout d'un coup montcornet
château porcien droit montdidier
puis ces noms ont disparu l'un après
l'autre et les français comme un certain
se sentir très seul sous un ciel qui ne
leur apportait pas de consolation car le
ciel lui même appartenait à l'ennemi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on oublia la drôle de guerre quoi
on avait cru que tout se passerait
tranquillement larmes à la bretelle avec
quelques jolies formules des belotes tel
vin chaud du soldat que tout se
terminera un jour sans trop de
dérangement et surtout surtout sans tout
cela sans tout cela qui crevait sur la
terre comme un orage et qui n'apportait
que le feu l'écroulement la peur et la
fuite et du sang sur les routes et du
mal pour tout un peuple égaré sur les
chemins du désespoir
vous souvenez vous de ces journées d'il
ya vingt ans c'était la fin et c'est
dans le tumulte amer de cette fin qu'une
voix par là puisque ce y avait le devoir
de manier l'épée de la france l'ont
laissé tomber brisé qui ramassait le
tronçon du glaive français va chez eux
vous avez encore une armée de pondre oui
la victoire sera transformé qui elle
sera gens répondent avec le concours des
armes de rang
vous souvenez vous
[Musique]